hey guys welcome to the just pearly
things podcast um i'm jess and this is
pearl and but welcome back to the
journey it's been a minute it's been a
minute i went to the states and then
pearl went to the states and so and it's
just been a lot going on but now we're
here and today we're going to be talking
about the real history of slavery so
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe on this video and i hope you
and sign up for what sign up for
memberships yes memberships there's
going to be a lot of things and you
don't want to miss out on the extra
you'll be able to see the stuff that is
posted on the channel usually but
there's going to be i made i made just
quitter day job and take over
memberships for me yes so it's been fun
though it's been fun so if you want some
like behind-the-scenes stuff
yeah behind-the-scenes content some
merch some little extra stuff then make
sure to sign up for memberships okay so
this is on the joe started from the
beginning this is from the joe rogan
podcast all right okay here we go
so uh do you know thomas sowell
i know that and thomas sowell was the
guy that we watched the one time you
know i'm talking yeah the older older
black guy yes okay
name why do i know that name thomas soul
is a big uh famous conservative he's at
uh stanford um he's at the hoover
institute i think anyway so you know
within this i mean first just to set all
this up we should set up briefly how
does culture work right and the way
culture works is that it like genetic
evolution it works based on blind
copying so what ends up happening is
that you are in awe of people right you
look up to people and so you blindly
copy the things they do and specifically
you start by blindly copying from the
outside and then you work in thomas soul
is a black guy right and thomas soul has
for years and years and years been
trying to fight racism but he's been
trying to fight racism by having a
conversation about culture right and the
fact that there are essentially two
different sort of you know to we're
speaking broadly here right but this is
for the purposes of communication um
we're going to tell a simple story to
start off with right so broadly speaking
he put
this is just a question that's been
running through my mind ever since we
started the video i know it's only a
minute in
has there
has there been any black people to speak
on
besides the second one that the second
guy that we watched has there any black
people that have spoken on what thomas
owell has said or is it usually like a
not a thing candace so once
okay is she the only one
no there's other ones i can't think off
the top of my head but he's he's like
been doing this for 50 years oh okay
guys so there's like there's so many
people that have reacted there's whole
accounts that are just made off of
reacting to thomas sowell it's like it's
like black people just reacting to him
wow okay cause i'm because i always
think when i see
white people talk about slavery i'm like
why doesn't a black person talk about
this stuff but then there's a lot of
other things that go into that you know
what so i always wonder like who what
matter who cares who's talking about it
if what they're saying is true yeah that
is true
i mean i could be wrong but like it's
just like to me it doesn't matter as
long as the information is correct yeah
i don't know i just always like
i don't know it's just like yeah i know
it's okay yeah
it's just a thought i was like these
white people
what do they know
i'm kidding
i kid i give
of people with dark skin next to each
other and one culture is these people
from the west indies and one culture is
this people group of people who grew up
in the south with slavery and all that
sort of stuff now
what one group the west indies group
does really well so a lot of the
successful black people people like
colin powell are originally from that
cultural heritage
the other group is the group that you
find in ghettos and african-american
communities and all that sort of stuff
they don't do well right they don't get
good education they you know shoot each
other they're all these sorts of things
and the reason why seoul has been
telling this story is because he's been
trying to say you know when liberals
look at the people in ghettos they say
ah racism that's why they're not
succeeding and seoul is saying no it's
not because if you look at this group
from the west indies they also came from
the experience of slavery there was
slavery in the west indies they are also
black so they also face racism and yet
they do well
so it has to be something else
and that other thing is the fact that
these black people who are in the south
there's always been a big question were
black people robbed of their culture or
did they preserve their authentic
african culture
and what seoul is saying is that they
were robbed of their culture and so they
picked up the culture of the people
around them and the people around them
were rednecks and if you look at the
white redneck culture and the black
redneck culture they have a lot of the
same values they don't particularly
respect education they love jesus
they use violence in their conflicts
and um they you know there's there's
just you know a lot of the same values
and a lot of the same outcomes and
yo
i've had that thought
before i'm like
there's so many like similarities
between
like
i'll say like oh like this group is like
a black group but then you have your
version of it
like for white people and i'm like
they're similar it's just like that's
the we'll say that's the rednecks and
that's the
it's the same culture yeah oh my god so
here's some crazy i know i've read the
book he's talking about okay
one out of every three white people
derived from that culture in the united
states
nine out of every time black people did
if you look at the economic outcomes of
the one out of the ten black people that
did not they're very similar to white
wow and the the rednecks
um
also have very similar economic outcomes
they had like one out of every four
dairy cows were they had in the
antebellum south yet they only produced
like seven percent of the country's
dairy because it was just really
unproductive
and there was and you know um
all the
the like whippings or whatever like that
stuff like it was it was just common
there like the white people were whipped
too
and like they they were there was more
recorded lashings of like the white
people down there than there was the
black people and and the other crazy
thing like which when i heard that stat
i was like there's no way yeah i'm like
no no that's where did you get your
information no no it's this book like
i'll tell you it's in my room i can show
it to you but no and then the other
crazy thing is
they um
like okay you hear it a lot in like rap
culture respect that was one of the
number one reasons people were killed in
the antebellum south is he looked at me
funny no he had no respect oh wow and it
actually came from england
yeah it's like from where we are now
yeah yeah that's no that's where the
culture but so we'll talk about this
sometimes the culture dies out where it
is
and it still is transplanted to
somewhere else so for example in in um
canada they speak quebec or whatever
there's something he used an example
from canada and i think it was that they
speak a language there that is died out
in like in france okay
wow yeah and it's it's so interesting
when i learned this i was like shut up
so
if black people never adapted to
the culture of
the culture that we were put in
we would be like in a
we'd be in a different position
but then
what would that say about
what would i say about the culture we
have now is it
truly like black culture is it just like
some form okay here's the oh gosh
like okay so a lot of the and i don't
even like saying black culture because
again there's one out of every 10 black
people that didn't derive from that
culture and probably more now with
people that came right
but
um
redneck culture
has phrases like you was you be those
dialects are from england
i've heard that yeah i've heard that wow
and a lot of um
the things they say is like black
culture they're really not black culture
it's literally from england
that's interesting
pearl i did not want another rattle
today another crazy thing when race
relations got really bad in the u.s
right like in the 60s race relations
were getting better before that but what
happened was a huge group of people from
the south migrated
so when like then you would see race
relations get bad
so like in the 20s 30s 40s basically
and i might be butchering the years
right but
they um
how do i say this
they
race relations were getting better and
they measured this with like instances
of hate crimes were going down there's
less like they weren't they weren't they
didn't have the like no blacks allowed
signs that the interracial marriages
were going up so all the ways they
measure race relations everything was
getting better then a huge influx of p
of the population from the south came in
that's when you see the the race
relations get bad again the signs come
up
and it was very similar with um white
southerners um in indiana
and like the way they described the
white southerners from indy like that um
from the south that moved to indiana was
very similar to like the racist writings
that you see about black people like the
words were like so similar wow
[Music]
like stuff like this
i know like not everybody's gonna
believe it and they're gonna be like oh
it's fabricated blah blah blah because
we haven't like
heard anything about it so it's like a
phenomenon to hear stats like this even
when you're telling me this i'm like hmm
i'm still like questioning it because
i've never
ever heard anything like this and it's
like
just imagine
if this was something that was taught in
our school system but if it was
something taught in our school system
then the trajectory of the u.s would
change completely and
yeah i mean instead i had
an ex-boyfriend that told me they took
him to a cotton farm
oh i've been to
weddings on a plantation i'm like
hmm this is interesting no they had him
pick cotton like like his school yeah
the school yes like they're wilded at
these chicago public schools he told me
that he hated white people that he was
like taught to hate white people in
school wow and i'm like what the wh
why would they do that wow
and and it's also that's what i don't
even like saying black culture because a
lot of it like like one that's what 10
of the population it doesn't come from
this culture probably more now yeah
my brain is going to be scrambled today
scrambled eggs coming right up
and even ebonics which is you know black
english is actually all from the west of
england so it's actually this what it's
from the west of england so for example
if you go to places like cornwall um
there used to be this amazing um
uh these amazing ads on british tv right
for this uh this devon custard or
whatever and they would always say devon
knows how they make it so creamy and
they all talk like this right and so it
doesn't sound like black english but
they do say things like will you be
doing that and we be doing this and you
be doing that and they be doing that and
so there's the use of that copula b
right where instead of saying i am you
are he is she is they are they just say
i be you be we be they be which is the
classic feature of black english
african-americans
right now
the point is is that mind blower mind
blower now let's imagine that how do you
think that thomas soul has been received
by liberal america
not well right
not well and so for example soul has a
book called black rednecks white
liberals okay oh his whole point
i saw that book in your room and i was
like
huh what does that mean i was like
what you reading in here
okay i know what book he's talking about
but you get it it's the black red noise
the white liberals it's the same culture
wow i know i do i do be getting weird
stairs and i'm wearing that book i'm
like no it's not like that
it's a good book it's a good book i
promise
interest
so
so
and you know it's crazy too when people
be like oh
i hate this they'll say oh you talk
white one offensive
two it's not even white like it's not or
like it's not even like you talk like a
black person no it's not black yeah you
think or what's west england
i want to go to west england now and be
like let me hear you talk just just say
we could do a video we could we could
write it off we could
that might be coming up travels just
hear ebonics point is that you know if
you actually and you know again like
soul is you know he researches the [ __ ]
out of this stuff he really does his
work now if you if you look at the
experience of african americans
after slavery after slavery they do
really they they start to make real
progress right and a large part of the
reason why they make progress is because
you start to get a lot of people from
new england either you know black people
from new england or white people from
new england who come down and sort of
reshape the culture they create these
schools and they're teaching those new
england values right it's those puritan
values of hard work tenacity all of that
sort of stuff and so there's all this
progress you have people like booker t
washington and booker t washington was
an actual slave and then after he got
his freedom he got to go work an assault
mine which is literally the worst job
ever and in booker t washington's up
from slavery he tells this great story
about seeing a schoolhouse right and
that you know he thought that going into
a schoolhouse was about as close to
heaven on earth as you could get
like this is a dude who wanted an
education really really badly and that's
a lot of what you find in the you know
early black experience in you know the
post slavery period
and in fact you know blacks you know
before sort of world war ii actually had
higher rates of marriage than whites all
of these sorts of things that you know
are now supposedly a problem and then
there's this turnaround right the black
experience starts to go south right it
starts to get worse and what year is
this around this is post world war ii
right so
um so post slavery
black people experience uh a rebounding
they're starting to make something
progress and i mean you know if in terms
of books to read like you know just of
because a large you know a large part of
what i'm trying to do in general is
really let's move to the place of all
people are created equal like let's
remove all these stupid distinctions
right and really i just want to know um
post world war ii is 1945.
what else have we been going over what
happened in the 60s
you remember everything that's when they
introduced welfare
that's when that's what it was after
world war ii that's when abortion was
legalized
that's when
wow the father was like all those things
so
the black community was on
like an upswing yes and then they had
higher marriage rates than white people
they there's accounts of slaves
traveling across the u.s to try to meet
up with their family at post slavery
yeah
and then they incentivize the government
incentivize the black community to take
the dad out of the home my goodness that
the question i always asked in my head
and i've asked my brothers and we've
talked about it and i'm like
what
was it
about
the culture
of black people that they like didn't
want us to know to where like he said in
the beginning we were robbed of that
culture like what was it that
shifted it or in the west indies they're
successful they're
doing all this stuff and then in america
it's
a struggle like what what was that
thing that
they did not want us to know for us to
be able to succeed in america well i
think they just wanted black people to
depend on the government instead of
themselves
so then they'd have the vote
all about like power i think anyways
this isn't
i would say it was like that maybe
further along it may i don't know
i'll show you what percent of black
people do you think vote democrat in the
u.s
a lot
do you do you think it was always like
that no because it didn't
didn't the republicans used to be
democrats and vice versa republicans
freed the slaves
why are they voting where why are they
voting for democrats
didn't
wasn't the republican party technically
the democratic party i don't know the
parties never switched that's just
something they say
to like
yeah so they so they never switched no
they
no really
they just say that to like why i don't
know why do they lie anyway
i don't know it's propaganda my opinion
i i want to say it's like 90 like 90 of
the black vote and you know what's crazy
too donald trump got the biggest
percentage of the black vote and and
for any republican in like 50 plus years
really yeah and and same with he did the
first step act and the second step back
which disproportionately helped the
black community but what did the media
tell you racist racist racist
wow it's like it's like uh and they and
i feel like they know that
black people
to most people don't do their i know
true most people don't do their research
but i know that
when it comes if you throw out the r
word it's like oh no we don't support
them at all and they
i think now i think i know that they
know that if you throw out certain words
to black people or say people did this
and you may not have any proof of it you
may whatever
it's a thing that's like we're not going
to support them because they're
automatically against us
and it's
it's crazy because i've heard that stuff
i've heard that donald trump did this
that in the third i was still like
hesitant like
are you sure what's your what's your
like stipulation behind it but then it's
like it doesn't matter what his
stipulation behind it if it helped the
black community it helped the black
community if nobody died or was put in
to
jail from it
it helped and that's a lot more than you
can say from
any other president or from my knowledge
well and he also did opportunity zones
so that was that was for low-income
neighborhoods that helped them start
businesses really yeah but you don't
hear about that he he was really big in
um school choice so we talked about the
issues that
um that are in the like public school
system right and it's not really fair
that if you're born into a poor
neighborhood that you're forced to go to
yeah school he wanted people to be able
to pick their school
and so you get like say ten thousand
dollars from like this the
each student say has 10k that the school
gets from the government
so so
when you went to your public high school
right the government got a certain
amount of money for you like the school
does and he wanted to say okay why don't
we take that money and bring and it
follows the student so if they want to
go to a different school it'll come with
them so you're not forced as like if
you're low income you're not forced to
go to a shitty school that's not fair
yeah like i'm i grew up in a like a good
family or a rich family right
why do i get to get a good education
everyone's entitled to that yeah that is
true and so it's like stuff like that
they don't talk about
wow
and then they'll just say racist racist
racist it's like they use that i think
when someone's actually doing good a lot
of the time
to deter you from the truth yeah because
they don't want you to listen to them
because just imagine
this is
just imagine
if
they they didn't do that and they spewed
out the truth
i
i believe that
he
he would have been reelected
and
america wouldn't be going through what
it's going through right now
honestly from yeah my knowledge and it
may have been in a better place but
people
don't know and they don't do their
research and they
they stick one thing i learned with the
last election there's certain news
outlets that
are
democrat or republican or in the middle
so they're going to push more democratic
stuff and then lie about the other side
or they're going to put more push more
republican and lie about the other side
or there's going to be even in the
middle but a lot of people don't watch
those middle um
middle
networks they watch either the
republican side of the democratic side
you know what percent of the media is
controlled by the left
remind me what left and right is oh left
is democrats okay okay okay and then
i don't know the exact percentage but
it's like 90 something percent of the
media is controlled by the left so
there's there's
certain people behind the scenes that
own all of the media companies wow yeah
and oftentimes what happens on twitter
who got banned the republicans or the
democrats
yeah and so that they silence us wow
so interesting
live that principle
and the problem is that in order to
really live that principle you need a
new narrative that beats slavery so you
know it's not if you go and talk to
racist you can't just say uh racism is
bad like that doesn't destroy racism
right right what destroys racism is when
you make sense of the things that they
know right they see you know people who
are violent in the ghettos or they see
crime or they see a lack of education
where they see that africa is poor and
you're able to tell a better story that
makes sense of the things that they know
but also comes out with the conclusion
oh we actually all have the same
potential
wow i want to show you one more video in
this series hold on
so
then we're gonna do
they also have the same potential i
believe if black people knew that they
also had the same potential
and
because they say it but then they're
like but there's this there's that like
ah
yeah
it would like i i do believe like it
would unlock something i've always said
that i'm like
if we
as black people unlocked that one thing
in our brain that is not unlocked oh it
would
they would like we would
be what we were created to be but it's
just like that thing that is not has
been it hasn't been unlocked and it's
not going to be unlocked unless someone
tells them
the truth and
no that's i don't have to say that's why
like what we're doing is so important
honestly because
it's
it's like they
they teach them that like slavery's
still holding them back but if that was
true why is the the group that was
derived also from slavery from the west
indies why do they they outpace whites
or they're at least equal yeah
so i don't i couldn't tell you that i do
have a question for you yeah
do you ever get
um
people that ask you
about um
like well why are you why are you
talking about slavery like
you're your people were the ones that
put us there you don't know nothing what
do i do i'm irish
i'm irish
have you ever had someone we didn't have
any sleep
have you ever had so much
but you're you're you're white so your
people did it and you're american so
your people did how you ever had people
like no but if i did i'm sure in my
comment section sure never in person
people are pretty
like [ __ ] to be honest like they don't
they're not gonna say [ __ ] to your face
i got you so
yeah if they ever did that's i'd be like
look at like irish polish german lithium
weight like what do we do everything
from over here like we came
my ancestors came after all this [ __ ]
yeah
yeah and i feel like a lot i wish there
was like a
not a poll but a i guess you can say a
poll to see like
what
what a percentage of uh i guess you
could say white americans
were derived from like less than one
percent really
it was only three percent i think back
then remember
most people didn't own a plantation
and what if you derive from the people
in the north that fought against slavery
yeah
and most people in the u.s came from
like there was a huge migration in the
early 1900s i want to say
wow
there's a there's so many questions
there's not enough time in the day
oh we got time
this is long-form content baby
i can't like form a question because
there's just so much going through my
brain from like what i've learned
growing up and then hearing this stuff
and then hearing the stature giving me
i'm just like
why why
why it's like the big question was like
this i just
kept and
why is it that when you see
see a black person talking like thomas
all and i've said i've said it in
another video why is it that we like
clamp up or we dismiss them and i guess
i guess you could probably say the same
thing about candace owens
ah i love candace
come on our channel
see
i don't think i've ever
sat down and listened
to a
like a full video of candice i listened
to
a clip or a snippet of
when um
i think it was george floyd
when
all that stuff went down what did she
call though
she called black lives matter did she
really oh yeah she's been saying for
years it was a scam oh i didn't i didn't
know that she called that because i
because i didn't watch the full clip
yeah i watched a little snippet that's
what you're talking about keep going no
no it was that it was that incident but
i i didn't see the part where she uh
called black lives matter and all that
and um
yeah i was just like how can you say
that you're black
i'm like you know i can't stand this
chick blah blah blah but
i guess people probably have the same
reaction with thomas all like how can
you say that like you're black like you
should be for us if you're not forced or
automatically against us and that's
that's a huge mindset that i've seen in
the black community and it's just like
learn like open your brain if you don't
agree with it cool keep it pushing
but
you may unlock something that you never
unlocked before and your life may be
changed from it
once you see once you see it you can't
unsee it so the next part i'm going to
show you is five facts about slavery
never mentioned in schools
okay so this is from a soul book but
it's just
yeah you'll see we'll see
oh i'm nervous
yeah see this is my favorite book black
rednecks and white liberals
the instrumental use of the history of
slavery today also underlies the claim
that slavery grew out of racism
for most of its long history which
includes most of the history of the
human race
slavery was largely not the enslavement
of racially different people for the
simple reason that only in recent
centuries has either the technology or
the wealth existed to go to another
continent to get slaves and transport
them on moss across an ocean
people were enslaved because they were
vulnerable not because of how they
looked
the peoples of the balkans were enslaved
by fellow europeans
maybe if uh
what does he mean by vulnerable like
they were weak-minded or they were just
it was like the weaker people because
back then it was
he had two tribes
did fight the winners would take the
losers
okay
so did
was there a fight that we didn't know
about and oh everywhere
the india the native americans fought
with each other
african tribes fall with each other
europeans fought with each other
and then alexander the great conquered
most of europe that is true
wow when you when you say it from that
standpoint it's like yeah the the losers
lost yeah take them when you like
explain it they're the weaker the weaker
people i mean why do you think black
people
sold black people into the slave trade
they weren't thinking they weren't
thinking oh oh they're black i shouldn't
they're yeah let me get this bag yeah
like i'm not i'm sorry
don't clip me don't clip me
because they had slaves so they they had
black slaves yeah i've i've heard that
yeah
no they didn't they didn't have it but
they weren't loyal to them just because
they had the same skin color yeah
because we're not even 100 loyal to
ourselves now and look what they do to
candice owens my goodness okay
jesus as well as by the peoples of the
middle east for at least six centuries
before the first african was brought to
the western hemisphere
before the modern era by and large
europeans enslaved other europeans
asians enslaved other asians africans
enslaved other africans and the
indigenous peoples of the western
hemisphere enslaved other indigenous
peoples of the western hemisphere
slavery was not based on race much less
on theories about race
only relatively late in history did
enslavement across racial lines occur on
such a scale as to promote an ideology
of racism that outlasted the institution
of slavery itself
so
i just a thought came to my brain
so going off of what he said how
um
[Music]
it was a more vulnerable
type of people so do you think
america
do you think the people that were
brought over to america
were the more vulnerable that way they
were able to be more like malleable to
a different
a different life because they were
weaker and everything
they were able to
be controlled more
do you think that's a thing i mean
partially yeah i think and
are you talking about also how they
picked up the culture
yeah it's kind of like okay have you
ever met
kids with immigrant parents in the u.s
how how long does their culture really
last
and it's always watered down with their
kids like if you meet a
nigerian-american kid yeah like two or
three generations they're not really
that nigerian like i'm not really that
irish or that german yeah we have a
couple traditions here and there
and like you know we like corned beef
but
i don't really do [ __ ] from like i just
consider myself american yeah you can't
like i don't know how much you can pass
down if you're in a completely different
place as a kid
i see it i see it a lot with um i see a
lot with mexican and asian culture like
they'll keep some tradition but in terms
of like speaking the language i've met
like
second generation mexican americans and
they're like yeah i don't speak spanish
i'm like how do you not speak spanish
and it was like their parents or
grandparents never taught them because
of they were in the states and they
wanted them to
fit in and says
man
man it's a lot wow
wherever a separate people were enslaved
they were disdained or despised whether
they were different by country religion
caste race or tribe
in east africa the messiah were feared
slave raiders and other african tribes
either alone or in conjunction with
arabs enslaved their more vulnerable
neighbors
as late as 1891 it was reported that
manuema slavers had demoralized
surrounding tribes destroying crops and
famine reigned everywhere
even in the early 20th century
abyssinians were still raiding other
africans and carrying off slaves
it was 1922 before the british had
gained sufficient control in tanganyika
to stamp out slavery there
arabs were the leading slave raiders in
east africa ranging over an area larger
than all of europe the total number of
slaves exported from east africa during
the 19th century has been estimated to
be at least 2 million
the form in which the story of slavery
has reached most people today has been
along the lines of the best-selling book
and widely watched television
mini-series roots by alex haley
challenged on the historical accuracy of
roots haley said
i tried to give my people a myth to live
by
this instrumental use of history or
so
he it's
a myth
sorry so
he's funny
so my first question is why
that last like bit that he was talking
about when
he was saying the europeans came to
uh east africa to get slaves
that's
no to stamp out slavery to stan what
does it mean by stamping
england stop slavery
okay so they came to east africa to stop
it yeah okay okay gotcha slavery
wouldn't have been stopped without
england they they police they had no
real real incentive to stop it because
um they really didn't have that many
slaves
gotcha and um like it wasn't a big thing
in england and what they did was they
policed the the slave trade waters
and they also stopped it in other places
okay gotcha which was like huge at the
time because no it had never it's just
always existed
my second question okay
what's the definition of a myth to make
sure that i'm i'm understanding the word
yeah it's like a fake story basically
it can't be it can't that's not the
definition i don't know i'm playing
i don't know what it is i believe you
because i i know what myth is
let's get the let's get the definition
the real definition the meaning of a
myth a traditional story especially when
concerning the early history of a people
or explaining natural or social
phenomenon typically involves
supernatural beings
to a widely held but false belief or
idea
so with the said
man that is on the screen right now
have you seen roots
no okay roots is
a big thing in the black community oh i
would say older older black community
like my mom's generation
and
it's like oh if you haven't seen roots
you have to see it it's tough to watch
but we gotta know our people we gotta
know what happened to us but to hear him
say
it was a myth
is
outrageous you created a movie
that you knew the black community would
watch
for the black community
created off of a myth
how was how was that beneficial
how is that beneficial at all because it
roots is is tough to watch it is
it is
i would say 12 years of slave is like a
i've never watched 12 years of slave all
the way through but i would say i never
never watch roots all the way through
i would say it's a modern day version
of it
kind of
people can correct me if i'm wrong but
to hear that him say it was a myth
do you okay do you remember when i said
slavery wasn't like that some of them
had like good relationships with their
owners and you looked at me like i was
crazy yeah which is amazing which is
fair because i the only reason i know
that is because i read booker t
washington's autobiography so he was a
slave and he was born a slave and he
talked about the relationship that the
slaves had with the owners
and and some people inherited slaves
right so they're in a position where
they have this whole plantation what do
they do they let them go free what's
going to happen they're not
self-sufficient yeah like there there's
writings from
i can't remember it's someone who's like
the statue they wanted taken down and
yeah yeah like you remember when they're
tearing all so this guy he and he wrote
that he didn't like slavery but he felt
responsible to take care of the slave
like he didn't look at it as i own them
he looked at it as i inherited
plantation and if i let them go they're
going to be impoverished
and and so i'm not i'm sure there was
you know in the antebellum south so
really horrible [ __ ] that happened yeah
but it wasn't everywhere that's the
whole point yeah that's a story that
they've taken
[Music]
one part of slavery that was really bad
i'm not i'm not trying to shed like like
oh it actually wasn't that bad it was
the best thing ever like no i'm not
saying that at all yes uh
it was they there's areas that it was
outrageously horrible bad
within
what you're saying and then
what i'm watching and it's like
what why why wasn't this
like something that was talked about but
if it was talked about
if this stuff was talked about in school
america would not be what it is today it
would be it would be such a completely
different place but then it wouldn't be
beneficial for the government if america
was different it's almost like it would
empower the black community yeah yeah
it actually seems like it'd be a good
idea yeah and
just i just they want the vote that's
like that's what i think anyway i think
that democrats realize that if they can
get black people addicted to the
government and addicted to
be like feeling bad for themselves and
blaming slavery then the government can
always come in and be their savior
so so when they're when they need votes
they'll say oh reparations and black
people be like yeah we do need
reparations and then boom they get them
to the polls
yeah
because like what you said before about
reparations when you said that i was
like
you can't say that
if i haven't then i thought about it and
i'm like yeah just imagine if
if the black community right now got
reparation yes it would help a lot of
people but a lot of people don't know
how to manage money well and it would be
it would be gone in an instant and it
would be right back to where they were
like okay you got reparations now you're
back in the same spot like what are you
gonna do to
help yourself and it's like i wish there
was
people talking to like talking about
this like if you do get reparations what
are you gonna do for what are you gonna
do to
keep your generational wealth going or
keep
whatever and not like run out
you know what else is crazy there was um
and i think they start this in schools i
think that's why they don't teach this
in schools yeah and there was um it was
called dunbar high schools in dc
this was a school that
um
this is before oh also in the 60s with
um
that was when they got rid of school
choice
wow which i think was the most
detrimental thing to the black community
okay because how are you supposed to go
up in income if you're if you're lower
income right how are you supposed to
move up with a shitty school
that's not fair
so now now they and they did this in the
name of
diversity
that's what they did yeah because it was
okay
they
this was when they mixed the school so
they said we have to do it by zip code
so so they have to go to school together
which sounds good a lot of these [ __ ]
sounds really good but the problem was
this one of the best schools for black
people in the u.s was dunbar high school
out of dc and that school was ruined by
this policy because that school was
school choice it attracted students that
wanted to work hard because it was known
for being really strict it was known for
having like really it was it was a
rigorous school but all the black kids
that wanted to go there like they were
better students
and and a lot of the first black
millionaires came from that school like
one of the most successful black people
back then graduated from that high
school wow and then when they they
switched this policy in the name of
diversity what happened they weren't
able to go because it it was based on
zip code so the best students didn't get
so the students that wanted to learn
wow and now and now it's like a shitty i
actually i saw it when i was in dc
really yeah it was crazy like gave me
goosebumps because i was like oh god i
read about this high school it's like
[ __ ] now i guess wow
and so i think like literally they they
started in the school system
because my ex-boyfriend well i'm like
why are they taking you to having you
picked cotton that's the weirdest [ __ ]
i've ever heard in my life yeah like why
do you why are you 18 and you hate white
people you should
when only less than one percent of white
people own slaves so then it's like
even if they did reparations how would
that work and there's no way people this
old don't know this information like if
they've been in politics for 20 30 years
you think no one's brought this to them
yeah so it's like why are you doing that
man
so
do you remember that story um
that we learned
i think we learned it in school but
it i cannot remember her name but it was
the young girl who
when it was segregated she wanted to go
to all white school to get a better
education
that's
that's crazy to think that it used to be
like that you used to be able to come
from whatever zip code you were where
whatever you were and be able to go to a
different school in a different area to
be able to get a better education but
then it switched to where you weren't
able to and now she's trying to i can't
remember if it was before this or after
this now she's trying to get a better
education and people don't realize like
oh this was a thing but since the laws
changed or whatnot like she's not able
education went downhill after that
because the schools weren't held
accountable because they get imagine
if i made money no matter how good like
if my content sucked and i could still
make money why would i make good content
true why would i put all those hours
into like just anyone yeah so when you
when you tell the schools oh it doesn't
matter how much you guys suck you'll
still get students
what do they do that like why would they
put in that much work yeah to to make a
good at like and you've been in public
schools where there's teachers that have
been there 10 plus years in their ass
and you're like how are you still
teaching but it's because
the teachers unions like
like protect their jobs so they can't
get fired after a certain amount of time
and on top of that they still get money
no matter no matter what wow
my my goodness purported history is open
to the same objections as other
instrumental myth-making myth-making
despite the impression created by roots
during the era of the massive slave
trade from west africa a white man was
more likely to catch malaria in africa
than to catch slaves himself
the average life expectancy of a white
man in the interior of sub-saharan
africa at that time was less than one
year
by and large men from europe or the
western hemisphere came to the coasts of
africa bought their slaves and left as
soon as possible
even so when he says bought
that's from
the
um what you will call it so when he said
bought the slaves is essentially from
the tribes fought and then it was the
lesser slaves and they were like here
you go
get these
these lesser beans out of here
yeah
interesting
even so the death rates among the white
crews of the ships carrying slaves to
the western hemisphere were as high as
the death rates among the slaves
themselves
it was only much later after quinine and
other medical measures enabled europeans
to survive where there were tropical
diseases was it possible for them to
invade africa in force and establish
empires there
but by then the atlantic slave trade had
already been ended
during the era of that trade africa was
largely ruled by africans who
established the conditions under which
slave sales took place the crew of a
slave ship was in no position to defy
african rulers and their armies by going
out across the land and capturing people
willy-nilly
the stronger african peoples captured
and enslaved the weaker peoples the same
pattern found over the centuries in
europe asia the western hemisphere and
polynesia
in the asa land the angoni and yao
swaggered over and terrorized other
tribes in uganda the baganda made life
miserable for their neighbors and the
niyoro and hima of anko enslaved toro
women and children the tutsi dominated
the hutu in rwanda the messiah lorded it
over the kukuyu and kamba and the latter
in turn held the indorobo in a kind of
serfdom
it was precisely the fact that europeans
except for the portuguese seldom
participated in the raids that captured
and enslaved africans that enabled most
people in europe and the americas to
remain oblivious to the traumatic
experience that this was with some
africans committing suicide to avoid
capture and wives being whipped as they
tried to cling to their husbands or
children
historian david breon davis pointed out
that europeans had little contact with
the actual process of enslavement and
that as late as 1721 the royal african
company asked its agents to investigate
the modes of enslavement in the interior
europeans typically saw only the end
results enslaved people being offered
for sale on the coast
it was much the same story in the
ottoman empire where those who bought
slaves had no idea what these slaves had
been through before
the unique position of the western world
in the history and especially the
destruction of slavery need not imply
that there was unanimity within the west
on this institution
so
he he said something um
about the malaria and
how they
white men or white people europeans
couldn't
survive
was it a year or a year
so essentially i'm just thinking about
just like
genealogy heritage
essentially nobody that
was in
nobody in america right now
i won't say nobody but they're not from
like
the middle
like middle areas of africa
technically i don't think so i don't
know like just going off of like what
he's saying that they're all from the
coast but then i was thinking like they
could have brought them to the coast but
it's still
so
so interesting my i'm i'm listening and
i'm like trying to
still be open-minded and like learn and
just hear and it
it's a lot to be able to like see these
images but hear what he's saying and be
able to
put it all together and then take what
i've been taught my whole life in school
and then just in the community and just
be like
what is this all and be able to be like
okay yeah
but it's a lot it's all yeah no it's
and and even the the slave the people
that like
ran the ships most a lot of them died
too yeah because the diseases
and that's when earlier he said it
wasn't about race because
we didn't have the tools to really mix
throughout history because of diseases
yeah it was a dangerous place back then
i mean there was a plague that wiped out
a third of the population in europe
really the black plague oh the black
plague i was like which plague okay i
know i know you know
i heard about the black plague addition
to whites who defended the enslavement
of africans on racial grounds or who
opposed general emancipation on social
grounds there were many whites and even
blacks who defended slavery as a matter
of self-interest as slave owners
although most black owners of slaves in
the united states were only nominal
owners of members of their own families
there were thousands of other blacks in
the antebellum south who were commercial
slave owners just like their white
counterparts
an estimated one-third of the free
persons of color in new orleans were
slave owners and thousands of these
slave owners volunteered to fight for
the confederacy during the civil war
black slave owners were even more
you know what's funny i was going to
quote this earlier but i was like i
gotta wait for her to see it in the
video
huh
so
yeah so how would reparations work with
the black slave owners would they owe
reparations or
i don't know
i don't know
the the confederacy
helped me help me understand the slavery
okay so there was people there were
black people that were fighting for the
confederacy
okay the freedom because because it
wasn't about race them they got their
slavery and they're like oh they got
sorry they're freedom for slavery they
got their freedom and they're like oh i
know how to run a plantation let me
start one
then they went and bought slaves ran
their own plantation
and then they're like oh [ __ ] you got
you want to take this away oh no
it's just it was an institution
like globally
all right gotcha isn't that crazy though
one-third
yeah
i just keep going back to like if this
was like
if the real
we i don't think anybody well i do think
there are some people who know the real
history of the united states and they
get keep it from
everybody
but if we were taught the real real
history of the united states oh it would
be it would be so different nowadays
but sometimes you know what's funny i
showed this to a different girl
see you're open-minded you can listen
and like take it in and she like
literally in the
in the video she says i don't want to
believe that
i'm like okay i can't it's
that and and that's like the
the hard thing
about um
about just the black community as a
whole you've heard this stuff your whole
life and you're like this is how it is
this is how it's always going to be
there's no change blah blah blah this
that in the third and yes there are some
struggles that uh come
with being black but it's like when you
hear this it's like this is the
breakdown of
what it was yes there may have been some
people that abused it but that's
maybe not how it started and just to
hear it that's why i'm like i'm like
quiet most of the video and i'm just
listening i'm like
like i said trying to just understand
everything's like if you saw my brain
it'd be like
right now
yeah i'm just like
you do so well with reactions it's like
written all over your face
i can't hide it because it's on my face
and i'm just like
no this blue it's funny watching you
because i i swear to god i was you
no i swear to god like i believed in
a lot of the stuff the left teaches in
college yeah and then i started to find
this content and i'm like
huh
yeah and it's like and so watching you
it's funny because it's like i see
myself like three or four years ago
it's it it's just it's it's mind-blowing
to hear this information it's just like
where do you i want to be like what are
your sources blah blah blah blah where'd
you get this from but it's like if it
was anything else i'd be like okay yeah
yeah that's true you're you're a
creditable source like that's that makes
sense but when it comes to something
like this if it's not something that
we
we've been taught our whole lives it's
like we have to fact check it and it's
okay to question people's sources that's
not
and i could give you the book it's all
cited and we're excited yeah but no it's
not i think you should question people's
sources always
we'll keep we'll keep going
more common in the caribbean
in short there were many defenders of
slavery in the west even in the 19th
century
he just said so i'll go back a second
okay
defenders of slavery in the west even in
the 19th century
and outside the west slavery was too
widely accepted to require defense
no other nation ended slavery in the
same way as the united states did and
few ended it after so short a struggle
as history is measured
how and why did slavery end in most of
the world
there were two major processes
over the centuries as more and more
territories around the world
consolidated into nation-states with
their own armies and navies
raiding those territories to capture and
enslave the people who lived within them
became more hazardous in itself and also
risked military retaliation against the
countries from which the raiders came
thus more and more peoples became off
limits to slave raiders over time
put differently the areas which remain
subject to slave rating over the
centuries were primarily those where the
people lived in smaller or weaker
societies
such societies continue to exist where
it was difficult for geographic or other
reasons to consolidate large areas under
one government
this was true of the balkans the
backwaters of asia and much of
sub-saharan africa
by the early modern era sub-saharan
africa with its numerous and severe
geographic handicaps was one of the last
remaining areas from which vast numbers
of people could be enslaved
that's crazy right yes clicky yeah
that all right i think more power to you
as far as i'm concerned
yeah it's
it's like i keep saying it's
it's crazy
and it
it's a lot it's a lot to process
and
[Music]
my my brain is scrambled i should i
should just prep myself every time i do
reactions like your brain's going to be
scrambled today jessica just get just
get prepared you're
not going to go in the same person once
you leave
and yeah it'll never run
actually you're almost through guys guys
we got a couple more topics but you
should have seen her in the show she was
explaining topics
to other people that i've explained to
her i was so proud i was so proud i was
getting a little nervous i was like what
is this coming out of your mouth it's
good like when i said uh we were on the
24-hour stream and i was like beta and
alpha and i was like
i literally my stomach started to hurt i
was like i never thought i'd use those
terms and i was like it's funny watching
you because that's how i thought i was
like ew that's such a stupid word
but you know what i'm saying yeah and so
i get it and so i use it i'm like this
is disgusting but i'm like here we are
oh my god i that was the work guys that
was the worst idea we ever had but it
was fun
it was fun it was fun though but i was
exhausted exhausted
wow so
and yeah i
i'm
my brain is so going how long how long
until you vote republican
i don't i i think i think we're close
guys i don't know will i be in the
states anytime soon to vote that is the
question we'll be back my next my next
election i bet
maybe it's like two three years isn't it
yeah
you're right
maybe unless i get hitched up over here
and i just stay
dual citizenship
dual citizenship oh my gosh but thanks
guys for coming along this journey with
us today make sure you like comment and
subscribe and sign up for memberships
and we will see you next time bye